Brian's with us in New York hey Brian
how are you mr. Ramsey I do so better
than I deserve what's up I would like to
start off by saying thank you very much
for taking your time to educate all of
us all the listeners and how to improve
our life well I'm honored
I wanna help today I'm calling um I love
you listen I have listened to you for
two days to be honest I cross arm all
about you through actually YouTube and
I've been listening since you know for
the past two days non-stop Wow videos
and also listening to the show live show
my wife and I we recently paid off her
credit cards and from the research that
we have done and this is my question to
you arm that we are debt-free as far as
credit cards and a personal alone and
just only one remaining thing that we
have it's my wife stood alone but um
regarding the credit card says the
credit cards are paid for would it make
sense to close them or should we leave
them open and now use it and the main
reason what I asked because from the
research that we did it pretty much says
if you were to close your credit line
it's going to have a negative it's going
to show up negatively on your credit
report so in other words you will lose
your credit score will drop to some
extent that is true your credit score
will drop to some extent and when you
quit using debt altogether and you have
no open accounts in your name you won't
have a credit score at all because the
only way you get a credit score is to
borrow money and so your credit score is
not a measure of financial success it's
a measure of how often you play
kissy-face with a bank so you know I
don't use a credit score as I don't want
to intentionally set out to do something
to harm it but I'm not going to keep
credit cards open to keep a false
measure of financial success which is
what a credit score is I'm not going to
try to prop that up by keeping these
accounts open you're susceptible to
fraud you're susceptible to start using
them again I would close them all what I
would do hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button
to get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim